>>HOSTING THANKGIVING IS
BIG JOB.
LUCKILY, TARGET'S GOT YOU
COVERED WITH INCREDIBLE SAVINGS
ON EVERYTHING YOU NEED FOR A
PERFECT FEAST.
BUY ONE GET ONE DEALS ON CLASSIC
SIDES AND SAUCES AND OF COURSE
BUTTER BALL TURKEYS FROM $1.49 A
POUND.
BUT HOSTING THANKSGIVING ALSO
MEANS HOSTING YOUR FAMILY, AND
THAT CAN BE A WHOLE DAMN THING.
>> I'M NOT DOING ANYTHING BIG.
>> THIS TURRY DRY AS THE DAMN
BOWL.
>> WE WANT FOOD!
>> IT'S COMING, YOU FREAKING
DOUCHE BAG.
>> HEY, WHAT'S THE WI-FI?
>> THAT'S WHY TARGET'S ALSO GOT
GREAT DEALS ON A BUNCH OF STUFF
YOU'LL NEED SPECIFICALLY FOR
THEM, LIKE HALF OFF NATE'S
HUMANE TURKEY LOAF FOR YOUR
NIECE'S ANNOYING NEW BOYFRIEND.
>> I DON'T EAT ANYTHING WITH
FEATHERS ANYWAY.
YOU KNOW, I WATCHED THAT NETFLIX
DOCUMENTARY.
HORRIFYING.
HORRIFYING WHAT THEY DO TO THESE
BIRDS.
>> AND AFTER DINNER, THE SAVINGS
KEEP ON COMING, WITH DISCOUNTS
ON WILSON BRAND FOOTBALLS SO YOU
CAN WORK OFF DINNER IN THE
BACKYARD WITH THE UNCLE WHO
TAKES THE GAME TOO SERIOUSLY.
>> AND TAKE THAT!
WHOO!
SECOND DOWN.
>> AND FOR YOUR DIRT BAG COUSIN,
TAKE 20% OFF MOTION SENSOR
LIGHTS SO HE CAN SMOKE
CIGARETTES IN THE DRIVEWAY.
>> YOU WANT TO TRY, LITTLE MAN?
>> AND $50 OFF APPLE
NOISE-CANCELLING AIR PODS FOR
WHEN GRANDPA WEIGHS IN ON SOCIAL
ISSUES.
>> THE DEMOCRATS WANNA LET THE
GAYS CHANGE FOOTBALL TO --
>> PLUS, TAKE 30% OFF PURINA
BRAND DOG FOOD, SINCE SOMEONE IN
YOUR FAMILY IS BRINGING THEIR
DOG EVEN THOUGH YOU ASKED THEM
NOT TO.
AND FOR KIDS, GREAT DEALS ON
TOYS THEY CAN DESTROY WHEN
THEY'RE LEFT UNSUPERVISED IN THE
BASEMENT.
>> TAKE YOUR BOTTLE, PEANUT.
>> PLUS, EVERYDAY LOW PRICES ON
WINE AND BEER TO GET YOU THROUGH
THIS CONVERSATION.
>> YOU KNOW WHO DIED?
>> HM.
>> JUDY FELDMAN.
>> AND THIS CONVERSATION.
>> THE THING ABOUT CRYPTO IS SO
EXCITING, BECAUSE IT'S ESSENTIAL
LIKE IF YOU THINK ABOUT THE
BLOCK CHAIN.
>> OR THIS ONE.
>> YOU GOT A NEW GIRLFRIEND.
GOT SOME NICE -- HUN.
>> PLUS, HUGE SAVINGS ON HOLIDAY
MUST HAVES.
BAND-AIDS, PAIN RELIEVERS, AND,
OF COURSE, MORE WINE.
>> NICE ASS ON HER TOO.
GOT TO THOUGHT OUT THAT THING.
>> HEY, SOMEONE'S GOT TO HOST
YOUR FAMILY FOR THANKSGIVING, SO
IF YOU DREW THE SHORT STRAW --
>> ANYONE GOING TO HELP ME WITH
THESE?
TURN TO TARGET FOR HUGE SAVINGS
ON EVERYTHING YOU NEED TO GET
THROUGH THE DAY.
>> HEY, JUST GIVE MY KEYS.
I DRIVE DRUNK ALL THE TIME.
>> TARGET, LET'S DO IT ALL AGAIN
AT CHRISTMAS